In the late 1950’s and 1960’s people began
to experiment with the idea of computer to
computer communication….
all information, no matter the form, is stored
in the computer’s memory as a sequences
of bits.
To send these bits they created hardware which
could transmit a clocked sequence of electrical
pulses along a wire.
On the receiving end the computer would capture,
store and convert the bits into the information
they represent.
Doing this with two computers, along a single
line, is quite simple.
But of course, other people wanted to connect
their computers together, too.
Leading to a computer network.
One simple solution to make this network would
be to connect all machines to all other machines.
but as you add more and more computers this
requires an impractical amount of line…plus
it’s incredibly wasteful.
Telephone networks at the time took a more
practical approach, individuals were connected
to a Hub (such as a city switchboard) which
was a point through which many people could
connect.
At this hub would be an operator with a switchboard
would manually patch people together by closing
a circuit between them (known as a circuit
switched network).
So if PERSON A wants to connect to PERSON
B, they both get patched onto the long distance
line through the hub.
the drawback of this method is nobody else
in the network can use the long distance line
until they finish their conversation.
We call this line the bottleneck of the network.
By 1972 the designers of what we now call
the internet were building ARPANET.
It began as a small network of computers at
universities on both sides of the country
connected together.
So they came up with a clever way of weaving
computer conversations together.
by breaking up all digital messages into chunks
known as packets.
The job of the hub is simple: Send packets
as they arrive from various sources on a first
come, first served basis.
each packet labeled by its source and destination
On the receiving end this weaving is undone
and the packets are put back into their original
sequence.
Effectively squeezing multiple conversations
along the line at the same time...
New cities were connected to hubs and those
hubs were connected to each other.
So more and more digital data needed to get
squeezed down these long distance lines.
But there is a fundamental limit to how many
bits you can squeeze down any line per second.
This limit is known as the line capacity (or
Bandwidth).
And as you add more and more and more households
to the network, then you’ll run into a problem
we’ve all experienced in traffic….a waiting
line develops
(waiting line visual)
If you are watching a streaming video you
will notice these missing packets as unwanted
pauses in your stream.
To see exactly how this happens, let’s do
a simple example and ignore all the people
on the internet except one household.
Imagine this household is watching a video
stream from Washington upstairs and downstairs
someone is watching an audio stream from California.
The video packet could take THIS pathway and
at the same time the audio packet could take
THIS pathway.
No problem.
But now let’s add another household to the
network, in a separate city.
And assume they also want the identical audio
and video stream.
Perhaps they are popular shows.
They have direct a pathway to the music source,
but they also need the middle path for their
video source.
This causes a waiting line, or queue, to develop,
so the hub will transmit two packets down
the line, one after the other.
This is what we mean when we say the network
is ‘slowing down’ - people begin to wait
for their packets due to queues which develop
at the hub.
so The BIG engineering problem today becomes,
how can we make these queues at our bottlenecks
smaller?
In the year 2000 a seminal paper was published
(Ahlswede et al) and it’s based on a clever
strategy for what happens at the nodes in
a network...
Instead of treating packets like cars, and
sending them one at a time.
The idea was to treat packets as numbers.
And blend them together using mathematical
operations, such as addition.
Resulting in a new packet which contains a
mixture of information from more than one
packets.
Think of these mixed packets as providing
clues about what’s in them
Let’s return to our example to see exactly
how it works...
Let’s say the video packet being sent can
be represented by the number 1.
And the audio packet can be represented by
the number 4.
When the video packet hits the first hub,
it’s the only one to arrive so it’s sent
unchanged along all the output lines.
Same thing happens when the music packet when
it hits the first hub.
But now look at the middle up, it receives
2 packets, and this time it adds them together
and sends the result as a single packet.
Notice now, both households receive their
packets just as fast for each household as
if they were alone on the network!
Finally the key step is to look at how we
can unmix these mixtures on the receiving
end.
Let’s look at Household 1 first.
It receives the video packet directly.
to extract the music packet out of the mixture
it needs to SOLVE for the missing value, by
doing simple math we all learn in school.
We know the Video packet = 1
And the Video + Music packet = 5
Therefore,
The Music packet equals 4.
And that’s the great insight of this paper.
We treat each mixture as an equation, the
receiving computer solves for the variables,
or packets, it needs.
This is in sharp contrast to how the internet
was originally designed.
Because it allow smultiple packets to travel
the same line at the same time, instead of
having to get each packet in line and wait
its turn
And this system practically works because
computers can now do basic arithmetic operations
needed to solve these linear equations incredibly
fast, millions of times per second
By 2020 it is expected that ~75% of network
traffic will be video streams and the traffic
from mobile phones alone will be 30 exabytes.
And we increasingly rely on our communication
networks for services that are considered
fundamental such as health, finance, education...
Therefore solving problems related to network
congestion is critical.
And network coding is a great approach because
it allows us to mix information packets instead
of having to get each packet in line and wait
its turn.
This video presented the basic principle of
network coding in a simplified manner, but
there still exist many open questions, as
well as new applications to explore.
Such as wireless networks, security, distributed
computing and storage.
An active research area in information theory
today is how to best leverage this paradigm
shift to network coding as we build our digital
future.
END